So having discussed several different scheduling policies, we have
to talk about performance. Now the figures of merit that
is associated with the scheduling policy are threefold. The
first scheduling policy figures of merit is what is called
throughput. And as the name suggests, what this is
saying is how many threads get executed or completed in
per unit time. So that is. You know, how
many threads are being pushed through the system per unit
type, so that's what you're asking the super, and
as the name suggests, it's a system centric metric.
It doesn't say anything about the performance of individual
threads, how soon they are performing their work and
getting out of the system, but it is asking
the question. What is the throughput of the system
with respect to the threads that need to run
on it? And the next two metrics are user-centric metrics.
The response time is saying, if I start up
a thread, how long does it take for that thread
to complete execution? And that's what response time is
saying and variance of responsing's time is saying. Well, does
the time that it takes for me to run
my particular thread vary depending on when I run it
on the system. Why will it vary, well for instance,
if you think about a first come first serve policy
if I have a very small job to run,
and if it gets the processor immediately it's going to
quickly complete its execution. But suppose when I start
up my particular thread, there are other threads in the
system ahead of me that are going to take
a long time to execute, then I'm going to see
a very poor response time. So depending on from
run to run, the same program may experience different response
times depending on the load that is currently on that
system. And that's where the variance of response time comes in
and so clearly from a user's perspective I want response
time to be very good and variance to be very small
as well. Now when you think about first come, first
serve scheduling the figure of measure that is really good about
it, is the fact it is fair. But, it doesn't
pay attention to infinity at all. And it doesn't give importance
to small jobs vs big jobs. It's just doing it
first come first serve, and therefore, there's going to be a high
variance, especially if it is small jobs that need attention of
the processor, and there are long-running jobs on the processor connecting...